[Music]
everyone's fairy tale was John and I
getting married like Superman and Wonder
Woman finally found each other and this
is everyone's happily ever after
so you just force yourself to believe it
too even if you start feeling something
different
Nikki Bella laying it all out there when
it comes to our breakup with John Cena
on the season finale of total Bella's I
definitely feel like I haven't been
myself for a long time I feel like I'm
starting the journey of finding me again
the wrestling superstars first split in
April just weeks before they were set to
marry no there's no other way to say
that that's it's a love Nicole with all
my heart and I want to make it sound
nicer for now the pair appeared to be
reconciling in June but in July
Nikki shared this update in a vlog right
now we're just friends we are both
working on each other and trying to work
on us and we talk every day
we absolutely love each other and maybe
there's hope that we reunite in the
future
[Applause]
[Music]